thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
episode
hey crazies i'm gonna be straight with
you i hate quantum mechanics
it hurts my brain but misery loves
company right so
let's take a trip down the quantum brick
road
first this is not a video about the
double slit experiment
i did that a few months ago feel free to
check it out later if you haven't seen
it
it's an overused example plus in my
experience
any specific experiment is going to
distract from the main point today
which is quantum wave functions what's
actually waving
yeah what's actually waving probability
huh
i'm going to explain remember we're
taking a trip down the quantum brick
road
it's a journey crazies anyway the name
has three words in it
quantum wave and function we better know
what those words mean
separately before we go mixing them
together a quantum
is just the smallest piece of some
physical property
that could be used during a particle
interaction like when an electron in an
atom drops down energy levels
a photon is usually emitted that photon
is a quantum of light energy when we
realized stuff like
this could happen we had to invent a new
type of mechanics to describe it
naturally we called it quantum mechanics
and lots of names for things
in quantum mechanics start with the word
quantum kind of like how a certain
company starts everything with the
letter
i alright next up wave
a wave is anything that has a back and
forth shape
they're often curvy and regular like
this but they don't have to be
they could be irregular or boxy or even
triangular they just need to have that
back and forth shape
so yes while wave is a verb it's also a
noun
waves are things get on board people
last but certainly not least
function by that we mean a mathematical
function
which is a relation or map between sets
of numbers
but that's a bit abstract it's easier to
think of a function like a little
mathematical machine
you put numbers in like maybe time or
something
and you get numbers out that depend on
that input
like the motion of a squirrel we'd say
that motion
is a function of time or just v of t
for short so this function tells you how
fast a squirrel is
falling at any given moment it's just a
way of showing that some measurements
depend on other measurements
now let's start combining words a wave
function
is a function that looks wavy surprise
the falling squirrel function isn't wavy
though it's just a slanted line
there's no back and forth shape we need
a back and forth motion
let's attach the squirrel to a spring
and give it a little bounce
put some moving graph paper behind it
and bam we've got a wave
the height of the squirrel depends on
time so we say it's a function of time
since its shape is wavy we call it a
wave function
and it's written using some kind of sine
or cosine
because we know those look wavy bouncing
squirrels aren't the only waves in
nature though
there are waves on strings there's sound
water waves
ac voltage waves on oscilloscope screens
and even light
all of them involving some kind of sine
or cosine that's all there is to a wave
function
it's adding the word quantum on the
front that makes things weird
but but we can handle it remember
quantum brick road
it's a journey okay a quantum wave
function
is a wave function for quantum things it
shows a dependence between two
measurements
that has some kind of back and forth
pattern and is about
tiny particles what two measurements
what's waving
what what what dude calm down
everything's gonna be okay
let's go deeper if a quantum wave
function is like any function
then it's a little mathematical machine
you put numbers in
and you get numbers out the input is
some measurable property about a
particle
where it might be what it might be doing
when something might happen
that sort of thing the output well
that's the tricky part
see with normal wave functions the
output is pretty clear
it's some kind of distance or field
strength or
something else that's directly
measurable quantum wave functions are a
bit more abstract than that
in fact they're unobservable by
definition it might help to look at how
they're used
i think it's time for an example the
simplest one i can think of
is the particle in a box for now let's
keep the box one-dimensional
we don't want things to get too complex
get it
complex you'll get the job later inside
the box
there's a single particle maybe it's an
electron but it doesn't matter
just go with it okay that particle has
properties we might be interested in
knowing something about
where is it what is it doing when will
it decay into other particles
of course this is quantum mechanics so
we can't know anything exactly
but we can predict the probabilities of
what those properties might be
that's where the quantum wave function
comes in say we want to know where our
particle might be
inside the one-dimensional box it could
be just about anywhere
but it has a better chance of being in
some places than others
its quantum wave function gives us some
idea of where
just by looking at it we can see this
particle has a better chance of being in
the center of the box than on the edges
that's just a general idea though it
doesn't give us an actual probability
to make matters worse this isn't even
really waving up and down
it's actually rotating through both real
and imaginary numbers
the combination of which we call complex
space
hence that complex joke from earlier we
don't want things to get too
complex get it complex
i'm such a dork the point is that the
quantum wave function isn't even
completely
real at least in the mathematical sense
but that doesn't mean we can't get
something real
out of it if you multiply a complex
number by what we call this conjugate
that's just a sine swap of the imaginary
part then you've done something called a
complex
square the imaginary parts cancel and
you're left with only real parts
just got real jokes aside
now that we have only real parts we can
actually make physical sense of this
instead of looking at the quantum wave
function itself we look at its complex
square
something we call the probability
density in this case
it's a probability per unit length
measured along our one-dimensional box
this view of the wave function is called
the born rule
named after max born who came up with it
in 1926.
this realization was groundbreaking so
we'd say this is the probability density
for position
it's best to think of it like a bunch of
separate numbers along the box
the height of each of these bars is the
probability density
at that location there are a lot of
possible locations for this particle
though
so there are a lot of vertical bars so
many in fact
that it all just looks like a shaded
area the total area covered by all the
bars
should be equal to 1 or 100 because
there's a 100
chance of finding the particle somewhere
in the box i mean we put it in there
ourselves right
but let's say we only want to know the
probability of finding the particle
between here
and here all we do is add up all the
skinny rectangles between those two
points
and the shaded area is the probability
it's that easy
you can clearly see that some areas have
a higher probability than others
what if i'm interested in something
other than position then you make that
thing your input instead
this was in terms of one-dimensional
position so it tells you probabilities
in position you want to know about
momentum instead
just transform the wave function any
areas you shade now
will give you probabilities and momentum
as long as the total area is
whoa wait whoa whoa that wasn't supposed
to happen
it appears our probability density moves
up to infinity in a couple places
what's that mean uh nothing profound
it's just that our example is a bit too
simplified in other words i was lazy
when you make a particle box that's
infinitely deep infinity is bound to
show up in a few results
i just happen to find one it doesn't
invalidate the whole process though
it works if you choose a model that's a
little more realistic
here's a more accurate probability
density for the electron in a hydrogen
atom
the input is the distance from the
center of the atom just like before
any shaded area gives you the
probability of finding the electron
within that range of distances if you
transform it so that momentum is your
input
you can find the probabilities for
momentum instead
see no infinities this time you can
write the wave function in terms of
anything you want to know
position energy linear momentum angular
momentum
whatever it's the same wave function
just set up to accept different inputs
so what's a quantum wave function it's a
mathematical entity
that has no physical meaning but if you
take its complex square
you give it meaning as a probability
density the total area shaded by it
should be one or one hundred percent so
any smaller area you shade
will give you the probability of finding
those values when you measure that
property
if you're interested in another property
you just transform the wave function
but the same rules apply shaded areas
are probabilities
a single quantum wave function contains
all the probabilities we might want to
know about
any property of a quantum particle and
ultimately that's all we get to know
so did this help you understand quantum
mechanics a little better
let us know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember
it's okay to be a little crazy becoming
great at math and science doesn't have
to be dull
brilliant is a problem-solving website
and app with a hands-on approach
there are over 50 courses full of
storytelling interactive challenges
and problems to solve if you watch this
video you probably like their course on
quantum objects
the course covers everything from
concepts to the unique mathematical
notation used in quantum mechanics
they even go deeper into those graphs i
spent most of this video talking about
brilliant is for ambitious and curious
people who want to excel at problem
solving and understanding the world
it's a great complement to watching
educational videos with well-curated
sequences of problems that help you
master all sorts of technical subjects
if this sounds like a service you'd like
to use go to brilliant.org
science asylum today the first 200
subscribers will get 20
off an annual subscription
several of you pointed out the
ridiculously slow drift velocity of
charges in a current
and you're right it's on the order of
centimeters per hour
give or take but relativistic effects
occur at all speeds
it's just a matter of whether or not
it's measurable and that depends on more
than just speed
anyway thanks for watching